[Musique]
avec perez de pradier yves lecoq
dany saval
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec corinne le poulain daniel prévost
jean marie avec jean paul blanc nicole
croisille et fatigué bonjour bienvenue
sur antenne 2 pour l'académie des neuf
nous avons passé un petit peu plus de
trente minutes ensemble à jouer je
l'espère à sourire voire même à rire et
apprendre plein de choses avec la
complicité de deux candidats vous
connaissez mari qui était là hier marie
bonjour bonjour va bien oui tout va très
bien et puis des cours auprès de
quelques-uns de ses des comédiens qui
sera encore ça ne saurait tarder je vous
ai vu bavarder tout à l'heure didier bon
je voulais vous présenter
oui je m'appelle didier je viens
dernière et je suis dans la comptabilité
dans la comptabilité
donc si tout vas y avait un problème
avec les à 2 1 pour nous départager le à
2 qui vaut cinq francs 60 nous sommes
bien d'accord et le premier jeu sans
plus attendre voici les 9 15
[Musique]
alors les neuf casse bien sûr c'est la
ligne avec une petite croix pour vous
didier un petit rond pour vous marie
c'est vous qui commencez puisque vous
êtes le bienvenu dans cette émission
didier alors avec qui vous voulez vous
jouer mais je vais commencer avec yves
lecoq avec yves lecoq bonjour yb
bonjour yves l'île du pacifique
nommé pitcairn fut en 1790 l'asile de
neuf mutins pas de neuf académiciens
mais neuf mutins d'un navire s'élève
qu'elle est chère yves lecoq
quel était le nom de ce navire top
chrono 30 secondes on dit la date là 17
1790 il indices 1790 10
alors qu'elle le titanic certainement
les mutins d'un navire célèbre yves
lecoq encore ce soir on parle pas de
chocolat non parce qu'il a le nom yves
allons y et les révoltés du bounty et
ouais c'était les révoltés du bounty je
regrette je regrette le bounty c'était
le bateau pas de petites croix c'est
avoue marie alors que faites vous je
vais jouer avec dany saval avec dany
saval dany bonjour dany les fûts gien
indien de la terre de feu étaient un
peuple de montagnards dont la façon de
se vêtir si je puis m'exprimer ainsi
était spécial pourquoi denis top chrono
attendez-vous pour commencer oui les
féron'arts est le chrome une seconde
alors les sujets un indien de la terre
de feu étaient un peuple de montagnards
dans la façon de se vêtir si je puis
dire était spécial pourquoi vrai que la
tête
non en fait je devrais pas dire la façon
de se vêtir qu'est ce qu'ils avaient de
particulier c'est fut gien là je vous
êtes vraiment donné un dur celle là pour
moi
comment demande carrément c'est à dire
pardon j'ai entendu et par moi qui
partent en chaîne
vous n'avez pas répondu mais ce que j'ai
cru entendre étaient la bonne réponse
ils n'ont jamais eu recours à la
technique du vêtement il était tout nu
il avait vraiment rien sur la tête
ailleurs
il avait beaucoup de poils pour leur
tenir chaud c'est ce qui fait la terre
de feu un peu de silence dans la classe
petit dans la classe d'actifs jouer
c'est avoue didier une petite croix
alors avec qui j'ai joué avec daniel
prévost
daniel prévost réseau daniel prévost oui
l'expérience aquabulles réalisé au mois
d'août 81 en corse doit aboutir sur une
première mondiale
laquelle est vrai et bien je vous dirais
qu'il y aura vraisemblablement je pense
à l'intérieur de sa taqwa bulle des
êtres vivants oui mais alors la première
mondiale ses coins et bien c'est celle
là ou non la première mondiale sait qu
elle descendra sous la mer non non non
il ya déjà eu des sous marins alors oui
c'est tout à fait vrai mais pas
l'aquabulle monsieur oui non mais
justement alors la première quoi oui
j'ai raison
votre réponse était intéressante certes
n'est pas complète
l'expérience et la première colonie de
vacances sous l'eau le livre vacants et
oui dieu quel bonheur ils vont respirer
je peux vous inscrire si vous voulez
aller me plaisait je peux vous inscrire
vous serez le responsable de cette
colonie de vacances dites moi c'est pas
brillant garder notre vie regardez notre
grille rien pour l'instant
alors marie c'est à vous maintenant avec
qui vous voulez vous jouer je vais jouer
avec permettra de libérer bonjour mais
un ogre russe fut excommunié en 16 180 à
cause d'un chien
l'église ne pouvait supporter cette
première médicale
pourquoi pérèle top chrono que j'avais
la rage non la veille à vg pas ils
avaient greffé quelque chose sur un
homme quelque chose qui appartenait aux
siens excellente réponse père est radié
excellente réponse c'était la première
greffe osseuse l'homme blessé au crâne
avait reçu des fragments osseux d'un
crâne de chien et l'histoire dit la
petite histoire dit qu'il se fit retirer
ces fragments pour retourner à l'église
c'est pas rigolo c'est tout et dégoûtant
c'est dégoûtant mais c'était une
question qui permet à notre ami marié
deux d'inscrire son premier petit rond
et 10 à 2 déjà didier houi enfin déjà
alors qu'ils jouaient corinne le poulain
corinne le poulain bonjour corinne
bouchoux jean-pierre corinne le
couturier français paul poiret fut dans
son genre le premier à un vrai pour la
libération de la femme
pourquoi qu'est-ce qu'il faille par paul
poiret vue de serre ou duriez poiret est
ce qu'il ne reste pas avant la
connaissez rohan lever les corsets
excellente réponse corinne bien sûr il
fut le premier à avoir supprimé le
fameux torché
à bien alors regardez un petit peu ce
que ça donne maintenant une croix bien
sûr que faites-vous mari je vais jouer
avec yves lecat yves lecoq pas bien un
médecin de hambourg suite envoyé en
15/100 21 au bûcher pour avoir opéré un
accouchement alors que lui reprochez
temps on va voir part d'ombré opérer un
agrément
que lui reprochez temps à ce médecin et
bien effet j'ai pas il avait utilisé une
technique sans douleur non non non un
médecin de hambourg fut envoyé au bûcher
ac le médecin non c'est pas une
césarienne qu'il avait fait non pas du
tout en leur nom il avait peut-être que
c'était une est restée que quelques n
ont pas du tout pas du tout et non qui
souffle je veux dire en fait perrette
avait raison d'après ce que j'ai entendu
tout simplement on lui reprochait
d'avoir assisté à l'accouchement il
était interdit aux hommes ni assisté et
il fut donc envoyé au bûcher et non en
effet eh ben oui quelle histoire enchère
daniel c'est à qui c'est avoue didier
avec qui vous voulez vous jouer je
jouais avec daniel prévost
alors là je vais être brillants ont fait
bien des certains vous faites bien
prévenir en 1802 albert mathieu dépose
un projet dont on parle encore car sa
réalisation n'est pas encore achevé quel
est ce projet le tunnel sous la manche
bonne réponse
alors là c'est vrai campus quand il
prévient c'est que c'est pas pour rien
marie membres jouer avec yves lecoq avec
les réseaux je gagne toujours
l'américain mario marriott établissait
un record mondial de vitesse qui fut le
dernier de son genre à être homologué
nous n'étions pourtant yves lecoq en
1906 de quel genre de record s'agit-il
c'est une course sa vitesse une course
de dr2 moto2 une course non non non il
était tout seul il était tout seul sur
un sur un engin ou mouy un engin à
moteur donc oui mais un peu particulier
un peu particulier c'est un an nino
106,6 oui c'était un truc à vapeur louis
bonne réponse yves lecoq en effet il a
atteint la vitesse de 196 kilomètres
heure sur un véhicule bonnes réponses et
regarder un petit rond didier je vais
jouer avec jean-marie proslier attendez
vous regardez bien la grille didier ben
oui c'est une une des deux hypothèses
vous avez raison si vous voulez par deux
des mois jean marie avant de devenir
peut être officiel de la cour de
françois 1er clément marot occupent un
emploi auprès du roi lequel un emploi
d'administration non un emploi de
service enfin je suis là juste qu'il
pouvait faire c'était bouché
dans la série ce qui s'appelait clément
marot donc donc ils n'étaient pas bonnes
donc un prénom masculin mais il est
évalué bonnes réponses il était en effet
le valet de chambre de françois 1er
regardez maintenant une croix et c'est
vous qui l'inscrivait didier
félicitations 100 à 2 supplémentaires
c'est-à-dire 130 à 2 pour 20 à 2 pour
marie attention marie attention m'arrive
d'aller sans doute pouvoir vous
rattraper maintenant avec notre deuxième
jeu le dernier des nymphes avec panneaux
au revoir jean paul blanc qui est qui
porte une double casquette si j'ai bien
compris vous êtes le manager de lili
drop et puis vous êtes également
comédien à leurs explications on peut
faire deux choses en même temps comme ça
jean paul pollin manager guy dreux
travail qui suit en coulisses oui c'est
un travail qui se fait dans l'ombre aux
revanches de mediaset en plein soleil
s'ils ont plus une lumière est là me
faut passer aux aveux alors deux mots
sur sur votre film de film dans lequel
vous avez tourné
c'est l'histoire d'un enfant simple
c'est plutôt un voyage mais s'ils
voyagent d'un enfant qui se fait dehors
pendant les vacances et qui se fait deux
dans quoi à la maison d'arrêt d'auxerre
c'est un drame psychologique 7 ouest
d'hier ça commence comme un peul ouais
comme un roman policier à moi c'est
comme ça que je le vois maintenant j'ai
vu plein de fois et temps en temps il ya
des séquences western mais c'est un peu
les deux morts mais y'a personne qui
meurt dans le film
bon alors je crois que le plus simple ça
d'accord avec moi c'est d'aller le voir
ce film il s'agit de petits joseph petit
joseph et vous êtes dans le film je suis
son père mon ingénieur informaticien
cadre au pc violent et sentimental
violent et sentimental sentimentale
violent peut-être dans le jeu que nous
allons faire ensemble maintenant si vous
voulez bien vous allez jouer avec
c'est avoue marie je crois bien avec un
léger retard 20 à 2 face à 130 pour
didier le tout une question lequel des
trois à votre avis jean paul blanc
quel est le roi français dans le surnom
était le père du peuple
louis xviii charlot neuf ou louis xii
pour les polluent pardon fois lui pollue
je l'assumé alors un des trois géants le
neuf chars le neuf
si vous êtes d'accord mari vous n'êtes
pas d'accord vous avez raison il fallait
pas d'accord du tout puisqu'il fallait
répondre
louis xii 462 elle prévaut 15 101 et
quelques enfin sur l'aura bientôt nicole
croisille c'est à vous oui nicole riz
l'image d'antenne 2 que vous recevez
chez vous les belles en couleur et très
très belles choses
dessiné par monsieur mathieu et de 440
et une ligne 625 ligne si vous voulez ou
819 ligue attend dé voir ses six ans et
quelques passes
avant 625 625 1126 sursis cet accord dit
j'suis d'accord bonne réponse en effet
se dit bien de 625 ligne pat il est
parmi ces trois inventeurs
quel est le père de la machine à
calculer le français pascal l'italien
galilée où l'américain edison qui a
inventé la machine à calculer jeu phrase
c'était
c'est très facile ça amd sun et dawson
vous prononcer très bien que faites-vous
mari je ne suis pas d'accord pourquoi je
ne sais pas alors vous êtes choix entre
pascal et galilée 4 pascal c'était
pascal en effet je regrette pas tilène
c'était pascal merci on va vous mettre
un petit peu à l'ombre pendant quelques
instants pour être radié c'est à vous
maintenant
l'auteur de l'opéra comique ciboulette
et reynaldo hahn quelle était sa
nationalité française italienne ou
allemande
si vous l'êtes oui française allemande
ou italienne
reynaldo hahn vite vers l allemande
allende
non je dirais italienne vous dites
italienne très bien la réponse était
française du merci merci beaucoup je
vais perdre votre petit badge didier
vous de vous replacer merci yves lecoq
léonard de vinci a terminé ses jours en
france en italie ou en angleterre en
angleterre en angleterre mais j'ai pas
se marie en france excellente réponse
mais en france près de tours clolus il
était le protégé de françois 1er revoir
monsieur lecoq merci beaucoup
un petit peu de vert devant vous dany
saval quel est le bruit engendré par la
cigale est ce qu est le crack est est ce
que le cas card ou est-ce qu'elle
frottis la tigresse
est le crack est d'accord vous êtes
d'accord
eh bien oui la cigale crack est bonne
réponse dany saval merci aux poulains
corinne les moutons de panurge
illustration de la psychologie des
foules sont des personnages de la bible
d'une oeuvre de rabelais ou d'un
pamphlet de françois villon d'une offre
de rabelais oui et puis donner une
oeuvre de rabelais oui je suis d'accord
oui c'est tout à fait la bonne réponse
merci en effet dû contenu
rabelais est tout près tout oui je suis
présent pour quelques instants que oui
l'un cesta punta vrai vous avez raison
et vous le prénom c'est bien la cesta
punta et le nom du bateau de magellan
une forme de reliure en imprimerie ou un
sport apparenté à la pelote basque
eh bien je pense que c'est la pelote
basque qui se jouait sur le bateau de
machine man
[Rires]
alors autrement je vous dirais la pelote
basque
laplaud demain mais après tout didier
donnerait la deuxième solution
et bien non daniel prévost avait raison
d'affaires raison c'est un sport qui se
joue sur un 30 ans spéciale de 56 m
félicitations daniel prévost ne m'étonne
pas de vous jean-marie brûliez
l'écrivain mark twain est associé à une
ville pour laquelle il s'est beaucoup
donné
oklahoma city virginia city ou los
angeles
j'ai beaucoup donné il nourrissait
beaucoup donné à qui et à la ville à la
vue seulement il a fait beaucoup de
choses bien 1 oklahoma virginia los
angeles au club oklahoma d'accord et
bien non c'était virginie un city dont
il était le maître à penser je regrette
jean-marie proslier merci beaucoup
d'être éclaircis ou s'assombrit c'est
avoue nicole croisille déjà
l'abréviation ccam décidément au tombé
que sur des preuves de télévision al
oula effet que signifie système
d'enregistrement couleurs à mémoire
service couleurs antenne magnétique ou
séquentielle à mémoire un loyer mais
séquentielle avec moi il manque des
lettres là non je sais pas on dit vous
me répéter la première version système
d'enregistrement couleurs à mémoire ces
systèmes d'enregistrement couleurs mais
moi je suis d'accord
vous êtes d'accord non c'était
séquentiel à mémoire avait évolué et oui
merci nicole poitiers ont boudé par
nicole croisille alors tout là-haut dany
saval l'animal ap les alpagas est un
animal des indes des andes ou de
l'himalaya denis pour des ânes peut-être
des indes bien alors que vous dites-vous
je pense des angles c'est vous qui
pensez bien marrer la réponse était des
andes au revoir dany saval merci à tout
à l'heure
et bien un match extrêmement serré entre
corinne le poulain et daniel prévost
est-ce que nous allons arriver les
départager quel est le plus grand
glacier des alpes
corinne écoutez bien le pasteur la mer
de glace ou la lettre
j'ai vu la mer de glace la mer de glace
en soit la dernière solution à la led ge
c'est vous qui avez raison en effet
didier merci au revoir corps il est bien
contre toute attente c'est daniel
prévost le dernier des neuf cette
affaire daniel vous allez peut-être
maintenant vous allez peut-être
maintenant pouvoir faire gagner 100 à 2
supplémentaires à l'un des deux
candidats si vous répondez bien à cette
question or quelle est la ville
française dont la devise est s'il te
mordent morlaix est ce gap nantes ou
morlaix
bien dit alors là attention je vais vous
réponds oui mais vite alors une seconde
il y avait une femme aurait morlaix
daniel prévost alors ça y est vous grâce
à vous daniel prévost une prime de 100 à
2 supplémentaires pour marie alors
regardé le match est assez serré alors
que brigitte vous donne les billes 180 à
2 pour marie et 170 à 2 pour didier le
public bien sûr comme chaque jour a été
interrogé sur les chances respectives de
chacun d'entre vous mais là messieurs de
répondre à certaines questions
voici les neuf a la cote en le premier
thème choisi les titres nobiliaires sous
l'ancien régime c'est à dire avant la
révolution
didier c'est vous qui allez commencer
vous avez un lui et géraud tard regardez
les codes qui apparaissent combien
souhaitez vous misez et avec quelle
académiciens je vais jouer 30 à 2 avec
yves lecoq 30 à 2 avec yves lecoq dans
la cote est de 20 contre 1 3 fois 2 si
c'est pas mal hein vous tentez donc 600
à 2000 cinq titres nobiliaires sous
l'ancien régime
avant la révolution top chrono baron vie
qu'on attendait baran un vicomte deux
comptes comptes non
marky mark i 3 duke duke quatre
chevaliers chevalier 5 excellente
réponse il y avait également écuyer ou
damoiseau banneret vidame et prince que
vous avez oublié mais de votre réponse
était d'excellente yves lecoq bravo
regarder le score il a bien évolué et
740 ha de maintenant pour vous didier
marie c'est à vous le thème choisi les
papes du 20e siècle
regardez les codes qui apparaissent
alors il faut vous jeter à l'eau
maintenant bien yves lecoq encore oui
20 20 à 2 2 x 2 4 vous tentez 400 à 2
vous n'avez pas rattrapé didier
l'intention il dit à 742 bon c'est ce
que vous 30 alors 30 à 2,32 et bien un
shérif bhl qu'aucune nouvelle fois c'est
à vous voulez vous me citer 5 pape du
20e siècle et cinq peintres pas peu bon
alors
jean paul 2 jean paul ii vol six pôles
623 j'emmène 3 10 12 pie xii qu'un
trailer jean-paul le premier à wii fit
et wii jean paul 1er voilà v5
[Applaudissements]
regardez dit petit à 2d car c'était bien
joué pour vous marie 750 à 2 pour 740
pour vous didier le thème les catégories
de poids de boxeur professionnel
voilà ce qu'a répondu le public et ainsi
nous avons pu établir les cotes de nos
académiciens alors les poids de boxeur
professionnel les catégories de poids
que faites-vous didier je vais prendre
jean-marie proslier wii qui étreint
spécialiste jean marie proslier pour 50
à 2 50 à 2 vous tentez donc 500 de
chaire jean marie paule y est vous qui
êtes un spécialiste
voulez vous me citer cette catégorie de
poids de boxeur professionnel c'est
parti souvenez-vous le mot succès avec
le poids coq je ne vois plus grands vins
velter pardon le producteur oui un coq 2
moyen moyen 4 lourd cinq ou six et en
manque un on ne souffle pas un super
welters qu'est ce qu'on fait là monsieur
le président chers
[Musique]
allez l'accueil 1190 à 2 pour 750 marie
les épreuves de courses maintenant et en
athlétisme féminin
regardez les cotes un site intéressant
comme code d'après le public qu'en n2
poule est une spécialité française avec
daniel prévost barbeau trois voies de 6
vous tentez donc 600 à 2 cher daniel
prévost trésor voulez vous me citez oui
ça bien huit épreuves de course en
athlétisme féminin doucement top chrono
huit épreuves de course en athlétisme
féminin oui d'accord alors la première
oui la seconde mais je ne sais pas
course à pied c'est une course à pied
oui c'est ça c'était bien non je vous
demande des maîtres des distances m et
100 m 200 m au sommet 100 m 200 m 2 2
400 500 403 6 1 7 5 6 1
et puis sans qu'aucun nom ça soit 150
noms une fois 7-6 1 2 ça tue j'ai vendu
c'est pour vous non non et non daniel
prévost vous avez dit 100 200 400 800
vous avez oublié 15 100 le 100 m et le
k2 64 x 290 arriver le 4 x 800 mais
votre votre candidature
réponse était très intéressante mais là
ce n'était pas la bonne moi j'essaie de
faire avancer le jeu me fait envie
alors c'est acquis maintenant de jouer
s'est avoué didier le thème les cinq
pays admis dans le tournoi des cinq
nations en rugby regarder les codes les
prendre yves lecoq le santal à santa de
400 yves cinq pays pour le tournoi des
cinq nations
allons-y l'angleterre 1 italie non
l'argentine non oui mais alors qu'on ne
souffle pas l'irlande de zanon monde
souffle pas non parce que l'enjeu est
important
bon bah là la france la france oui 3 du
cycle est là la côtelette la coop des
tno et thierry roland qui sera là demain
vous vendez cours l'écossé le pays de
galles vous allez oui là là là et je
regrette je regrette c'est à vous marie
maintenant pour conclure le thème les
rimes en roue des noms comme un air eau
eu des rimes en roux tenez regardez un
petit peu nos écrivains ce qu'ils ont
comme cote que faites-vous marie 40 avec
nicole croisille 40 avec nicole
croisille 4 x 2,8 vous tentez 8,5 de
nicole houle et vous me citer 5
rim en roue ou alors yarou d'accord 1
avec le r oui non je projet m hier à
chaque fois cette fois une ride
marie sissi avec le ou le rouergue avec
le r oui avec 5 vite 10 secondes et que
brou avis jetant c'est pas d'avis mais
c'est beau non
oui bout c'est bon de zap ou des bateaux
lapoutroie un trou un trou 4
yahvé kourou et cruz froufrous garou
kangourou loup garou route est longue
route vers et éboué yade et daniel
prévost et bien le score final me la 90e
2 et 682 pour paris de toute façon vous
serez là tous les deux deux mains bien
entendu et demain nous retrouverons tous
les candidats qui ont joué avec nous
cette semaine pour les enchères de 9 son
appétit demain c'est à 12h07 sur antenne
de revoir et merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]